thank you Allison for the really nice
introduction and thank you all for
coming to the seminar I'm really excited
to be here with you today
um so yeah I am the director of the
material robotics lab here at bu and I'm
excited to be telling you a little bit
about the research that we have going on
now we've been at bu for about five
years
um so I want to start with what really
motivates me and my students to wake up
every morning and get into the lab and
do you know work and and keep ourselves
I guess motivated which is solving open
societal challenges in healthcare so
addressing open societal challenges when
it comes to making robots that can
enable easier more intuitive surgical
procedures to perform and also enable
new surgical procedures that are not
possible to perform today maybe some of
you are familiar with the idea of open
surgery where basically a patient is
going to be literally cut open and the
surgeon has full awareness of what is
going on within the surgical environment
so they have direct visualization of the
environment that direct active feedback
because they can touch the organs and
they can feel what is going on but
really what we want to do is move
towards more of a minimal invasive
surgical scenario where you don't really
have to perform cuts to access the
surgical Target area but you navigate to
that surgical Target area in a minimal
invasive way which means that you are
accessing the target area through
natural revises for example so think
about navigating to the to the brain by
accessing your nostrils or accessing
through the mouth and reaching the lungs
and going and exploring the lungs to
look for a tumor take a biopsy that type
of thing so this is great because
patients don't have any post-operative
complete education scarring infections
and they basically can walk outside of
the operative room the same day however
there are many other problems associated
with this which basically have to deal
with the complexity of Performing that
procedure so surgeons have to undergo
years of training because steering and
controlling these flexible instruments
is a little bit more complicated to do
and so we want to build robots that can
do these procedures better and help
surgeons perform their their day-to-day
job better return some level of
information that they don't really have
and return some levels of dexterity at
the distal end of those instrumentations
so you have to imagine like if you want
to control a hose and you want to
control the flexible tape of that
instrument is really difficult to do it
you know when you when you have such
long flexible instruments like
endoscopes for example
and so these clinical applications these
medical applications I would say really
give us the opportunity of these are
case studies that are really good for
roboticists like Engineers or bodices
like myself because we are in really
interested in solving fundamental
fundamental questions and open
challenges in robotics Associated for
example with robotic navigation robotic
manipulation so for instance what is
more you know uh challenging than
navigating into
environments like these ones to the
colon is a very unstructured flexible
environment when you have a robot
navigating through its stretches and
moves and same thing here navigating
inside the lungs it's really difficult
because it's a maze of the very
different uh I would say tubes you know
branches of bronchitis that you have to
navigate into to get to the location
where the tumor is located for example
and so now navigation is a really
challenging problem in these fields in
these application scenarios manipulation
too you can think of you want to access
a tumor located in the brain maybe in a
deep seated location within the brain
and you want to remove that tumor
but how are you going to be doing that
preserving the healthy tissue
surrounding the brain because at the end
of the day yes you want to treat the
tumor but you don't want that patient to
wake up with some narrow moderate
functionalities impaired or
neurocognitive functionalities and it's
super crucial how you interact and
manipulate the brain tissue and so these
are all really great case studies that
allow us to tackle fundamental robotics
challenges especially related to how we
are going to be building these robots
I'm a really
my lab is really Hardware design focused
because we cannot like really buy a
commercial robot and you know just use
that for these types of applications our
focus on a day-to-day basis is talk to
our collaborators talk to our surgeons
that are collaborating with us
understand the clinical problems that
they have on a daily basis and engineer
a robotic solution to it so we have to
start from scratch when we do that and
sometimes this also means that we have
to develop the Manufacturing
Technologies to build these robots and
so we have to think about how we're
going to be building actuators and
sensors how we're going to be
manufacturing them and integrating them
inside our robots and we have to think
about how these robots are going to
transmute forces onto the tissue we have
we want to have effective robotic
systems to do that
and so in my lab we have been
investigating three classes of different
soft surgical robots to do that which
are soft Continuum robots
soft reactive skins and in this uh part
of the talk I'm going to be focusing
mostly on how we integrate soft sensors
inside our robots specifically focusing
on soft Optical sensing
and then hybrid soft rigid
robotic mechanisms so robots that
basically want to combine The Best of
Both Worlds when it comes to Soft
Robotics which is which has many
advantages so you have soft materials
that can easily and safely interact with
the human body but at the same time you
have rigid components that allow these
soft robots to perform a little bit
better and sort of like have higher
Force transmission or stiffening or even
being able to be folded down into really
tiny compact configurations and then use
origami inspired mechanisms to unfold
open up pop up the robot and then
perform a surgical task
so with soft Continuum robots we've been
mostly focusing on Interventional
bronchoscopy and the reason why that is
is that lung cancer is the deadliest
cancer today it kills more patients than
prostate breast and colon cancer
combined and so one of the reasons why
that is is that it is very difficult to
navigate to the peripheral part of the
lungs so over here
and that's where approximately 80
percent of lung cancers are located and
if you were able to reach that position
early on and were able to diagnose
cancer early on and treat it early on of
course you would be able to
achieve a higher survival rate and so
we've been working on this robot that
was actually published in Soft Robotics
a couple of years ago and hope I hope
you can appreciate how much small it is
smaller it is with respect to for
example a traditional bronchoscope over
here you can even pass it through the
working channel of a traditional
bronchoscope so this is actually the
smallest most flexible robotic
bronchoscope these days it has a
diameter of 2.4 millimeters
and in this diameter we were able to
integrate one degree of Freedom Bonding
actuation mechanism a micro camera and
two working channels two working
channels are beneficial because when you
are at the surgical Target area right
here and you start poking into the
tissue and taking biopsies and so on of
course you know you'll have blood you'll
you'll have bleeding and that of course
gets in front of your camera so having
two working channels basically restores
that ability of doing multiple tasks and
so as you're poking the tissue you can
probably clean up the camera
aspirate and do some something more
useful without having to pass
instruments back and forth and switch
instruments with only one working
Channel
so I won't go too much in the interest
of time I won't go too much into the
mechanical characterizations of this
robot and the workspace but really what
I wanna to talk about is you know what
we did in terms of xvivo tests so making
sure that we were able because this
robot is soft and it's so small that we
were still able to perform tissue
puncturing to perform biopsies but also
we have this system has two working
channels so that we can potentially
inject
uh drags into the lungs and so the
reason why we want to do that is that
typically when you go screening for lung
cancer you know you take a biopsy then
they analyze the biopsy and the patient
goes home and they are waiting a long
time to get the results but then after a
few weeks you hear back and if it's
cancer you have to go back and do
surgery again right that's not really
effective at all because at that time
you know weeks months will pass and your
lung cancer goes maybe from stage one or
two to stage three and four and maybe
you know there is nothing really more to
do wouldn't it be great if we have
robotic technology that would allow us
to take a patient in have them being
screened for a biopsy procedure and then
when they wake up you know your surgeon
will tell you well you know bad news we
found that you have cancer but the good
news is that we have already treated you
and you can back come back in six months
or a year just for follow-up you know so
that more lives would be saved at the
end of the day
and so one thing that we really uh was
we're excited about with this um soft
robotic bronchoscope that we created is
the fact that also keeps Visions sensing
integrated at all times during a
surgical procedure which is crucial to
help surgeons achieve a better hierarchy
uh biopsy uh and uh and also a
diagnostic yield so by using computer
Regional algorithms we were able to
basically create a robot that is sort of
like semi-autonomous and so the the
surgeon can basically
um use a graphic user interface to
command the robot to navigate to a
specific pre-planned
location within the lungs and it would
just you know click where where they
want to go the robot would align into
that location and then they can it can
be pushed and propelled forward and the
other thing of course is by using
computer vision algorithms we can help
the robot compensate for breathing
motion and so you have to imagine that
the lungs are expanding quite a lot as
you're breathing and you know the
surgeon is performing a biopsies and so
you have to be sure that you're actually
puncturing where the tumor is and so
compensating for that type of motion is
very important for us
um and so taking a step forward what we
did was actually we've been creating
um these soft miniaturized robots like I
said compensating for breathing motion
and taking biopsies but really as you're
scaling soft robots down the amount of
force that you actually can output
through these robots is also scaling
down quite substantially and so we came
up with other interesting questions
about for example well how are we going
to be able to make sure that this robot
is capable of puncturing through very
effectively how is it going to be
controllable within the lungs as it's
performing the procedure and so over
here this paper that we published very
recently this year the soft robot is
capable of deploying soft robotic
actuators to Anchor itself through the
surrounding bronchi Anatomy
and that helps the robot be more
accurate but at the same time it also
helps the robot sustain a higher level
of force output as we are trying to
Target you know a biopsy and so over
here basically I'm gonna skip quickly
maybe through some of these things but
over here we were able to demonstrate
that we're able to achieve pretty high
output forces which are way above the
range of you know the surgical tasks
that we want to do as we are performing
biopsy procedures
and we were also able to demonstrate
that we have created origami inspired
soft robotic mechanisms that can help
the surgeon control the needle
deployment inside the the lungs to take
biopsies such as for example in this
case we have a needle attached to a soft
robotic origami inspired actuator that
can basically command the puncturing of
the tissue and next steps over here are
going to be integrating also steering
because sometimes when you are at a
location when you want to take a biopsy
the tumor is located maybe close by and
so you have to achieve pretty sharp
bending angles to make sure that you can
puncture your way through
and so in this in vitro test we have
a 3D printed model of a bronchi where we
basically have our robot navigating to
at this point the robot is stabilizing
itself around the surrounding Anatomy so
that it can be more accurate and
puncture its way through the lungs over
here this is a gelatin model of the
lungs we demonstrated that we are still
able to steer the needle in case that's
necessary of course we will have also
intraoperative Imaging CTE scans as we
are performing the procedure and then
we're able to deploy the needle inside
the lungs hopefully to get where the
tumor is and over here the dye that
you're seeing is just assimilated die
that you know we use to see to make sure
that we're actually puncturing through
the lung tissue
so Switching gears a little bit I want
to talk a little a little bit about soft
robotic skins soft reactive skins and
like I mentioned in my introduction
these are soft robots that you can wrap
around any type of medical
instrumentation to robotize it so they
are dense with soft sensors and
actuators and in this case these are
soft Optical sensors my student
expressing up upon them and as you can
see the soft sensor is triggering the
inflation of a soft robotic actuator the
way that we are realizing these is just
basically we are using different types
of soft elastomers as you can see here
um and by playing with refractive index
of these soft elastomers we're capable
of
transmitting light through these wave
guides that you see over here
and so transmitting light through and
then if you press on these sensors they
will uh the the sensor response will
change and you're able to track pressure
forces banding and a variety of other
things that I'm going to talk about and
one application that we had in mind here
was Interventional colonoscopy so
sometimes in colonoscopy you know as
you're pushing the colonoscope inside
the colon to navigate you might have
excessive force concentration and of
course if you're a healthy person it's
not too much of a huge deal but if you
are not and you already have some
comorbidities this can potentially cause
perforations bleeding
if you are located in a place in the
world where you don't have access to
Anesthesia or you know good good large
hospitals you might want to have
something like this where you have a
soft robot that allows the surgeon to
perform a gentler safer procedure my dad
actually recently underwent a
colonoscopy procedure my family lives in
the south of Tuscany in Italy in a
really small town they don't have
anesthesiology in their hospital so he
underwent this colonoscopy procedure and
it was so painful for him and he's a
tough guy and he was so painful for him
that he couldn't like withstand the
procedure and so when I told him about
the research that we do in my lab of
course he was like oh when when can I
get you know your instrument to do this
procedure unfortunately not really soon
um but anyway so what we do is basically
like I said use these sensors to trigger
the inflation of these soft robotic
actuators sort of like airbags if you
will that can help the surgeon
distribute these forces and pressure and
hopefully have a gentler procedure I
want to show you this in vitro simulated
task that we did where this is a model
of a column where we basically show that
if we apply too much force within our
colonoscope the soft robotic actuators
are capable of deploying and we are also
capable of like I said if we have a very
concentrated amount of force by
triggering these soft robotic actuators
we can distribute that around a larger
area to make the procedure a little bit
more gentle for the patient
and then we took this a step further by
amplifying that haptic feedback back to
the surgeon so this is the soft robotic
sleeve that we have over here and as we
are pressing on it we are returning that
haptic sensation back to the surgeon as
they are wearing a softer Body Glove
over here and we were able to test this
together with a surgeon that is
collaborating with us a Brigham and
Women's Hospital
this person is especially is an expert
surgeon we are hoping to start testing
on novice people as well but the goal of
this is really providing that level of
extra awareness for the clinician such
such that they can be able to perform
better procedures and then again
for for a more of a trained person you
would be able to still see
um
an improvement in the procedure we might
we measured the NASA task load for our
surgeon and we're able that to see that
the mental and physical workload was
diminishing for them as they were
performing that procedure but you can
imagine that even if you were taking
somebody novice that would help them you
know be more trained and be able to
perform a better procedure in the long
run so these Technologies can not only
help people patients and surgeons as
they are performing the procedures but
even can help during training
um regarding haptic feedback we've been
focusing not only on Interventional
colonoscopy and the project that I just
talked about which is funded by NIH but
also we are tackling
um other aspects of haptic feedback in
remote repulpation or robotic assisted
palpation so by using Soft Robotics and
microfluidics we are able to perform to
manufacture really tiny soft actuators
that can be positioned at the finger pit
the fingertips over here in integrated
in robotic soft robotic wearable gloves
and what we do is basically Again by
using soft Optical sensors in this case
this is so easy and super cheap to
manufacture because these are literally
flexible tubes that we are integrating
in our
sensors and they are very inexpensive
and easy to manufacture and over here
again we're showing how we are using
microfluidics to create our soft robotic
actuators and so what we do is basically
we have this soft
sensor that is mounted at the end factor
of a robot and it is basically palpating
a tissue model where we have embedded a
tumor so like a high um higher stiffness
um material in here and when we are
basically
sensing that tumor these actuators are
going to you know return that haptic
feedback back to the surgeon this is a
paper actually that we currently have
under review
but again there is so much more that you
can do with this soft Optical sensing
technology that we have developed and I
just want to touch upon quickly two
other applications that we are we're
looking into which are
soft Optical sensors for shape
and contact
ing so in this case this is a soft
Continuum robot with a with a module
over here that has multiple degrees of
freedom and a soft robotic gripper
mounted at the tip and we are able to
not only track the shape of the robot
and the gripper but also detective the
robot is contacting objects and
interacting with the surrounding
environment
so how do we do that this is the module
it has soft Optical sensors embedded
inside these ones over here it's only
one sensor at the gripper and by using
um
roughness tuning we can tune the optical
properties of that sensor so we are
roughening the tip of our mold
over here and that roughen roughness
actually translates into the soft
Optical sensor such that basically we're
able to have from only one sensor a
multi-modal response and so the sensor
is capable capable not only to track
shape but also contact and so as you can
see here when our gripper is moving
we're getting the response that we're
supposed to be getting but then as it's
touching an object we're getting a
different type of response and we can
track that contact and the cool thing
about that is that you can track these
two different
inputs and how you do that is basically
I want to show you a live plot of this
so as the gripper is deploying an
opening you have this type of response
but then if you have an object placed at
the gripper Jaws you basically have
different types of different type of
response which basically gets you that
information that your looking for
whether or not there has been contact
with just one sensor integrated
the cool thing about this robot is we're
looking into potentially having it
applied in minimally invasive surgical
applications so for example a scenario
like this in laparoscopy
and so we were able to test this this is
a recent work that we currently have on
the review we were able to test this in
a sort of like pick and place pack
transfer tasks scenario where we pick up
an object and we move it to look at
point A to point B and recently we've
been not only capable of tracking the
shape of the gripper and the robot and
returning information about whether or
not there has been contact but we are
also able to track and and sense how
much force we are applying onto the
object which is crucial in applications
again like minimal invasive surgery but
you could think of any other type of
application like
environmental exploration any type of
really application in robotics where you
would benefit from having a really
sneaky sneak snake-like robot and to to
manipulate the environment and grasp
objects and so on
and then again just one really quick
other thing that we can do with this
technology of soft Optical sensing
we have been looking into other types of
clinical applications such as for
example bleeding detection this is very
important in applications like
colonoscopy for example where you have a
camera located at the distal end of the
instrument but you don't really have any
other information about sensor and any
other sensors along the length of the
and the scope and so you don't have any
information about what's going on in the
back and so sometimes like I said if
you're applying too much force or the
patient has any other comorbidities you
might get bleeding and you end up
knowing that there has been bleeding
actually only when you're pulling away
the instrument right and so we've been
looking at soft Optical sensors that can
detect bleeding and you could think
about having them position distributed
along the length of your tool of your
colonoscope and so over here we have a
soft Optical sensor a U-shaped soft
Optical sensor and by using
microfluidics we're capable of basically
picking up bleed blood that has you know
been
that is in the colon the blood will
enter our microfluidic Channel and the
soft Optical sensor here will detect
that just by measuring the refractive
the change in refractive index within
the microfluidic channel
so the way that this works is again you
have light going through this waveguide
and when this is a analog blood
synthetic blood and when blood is
passing through this micro Channel this
will basically the sensor will basically
pick it up and the cool thing about this
is that we were able to demonstrate that
we are capable of measuring different
concentrations of blood and So based on
the sensory response and the bandwidth
you can track whether there has been a
minor bleeding or there's a hemorrhage
going on and so you can alert surgeons
about that
we are able to differentiate between
blood and other types of fluids within
the body so for example in the colon
gastric fluid and so we know
how they're how the sensor is going to
respond and in the future we're hoping
to use this technology as a biosancer
for other types of you know maybe maybe
diagnosis of other morbidities other
illnesses within the colon or in other
locations of the body
um this is
um an in vitro test in a simulated colon
environment where we were able to
validate our sensor uh working and
picking up blood over here and we're
hoping uh actually arring my student is
kindly doing X Vivo tests on
explanted column models with our
collaborators and hopefully over the
summer and in the fall we're planning on
doing in Vivo studies on this so in live
actual uh pristine models so very
excited about that
um and then I want to switch gears one
last time and talk about hybrid soft
foldable robots so like I mentioned over
in this area of research that we
currently have on going on in the
material robotics lab what we are
looking at is combining The Best of Both
Worlds when it comes to Soft Robotics
for surgical applications and rigid
origami inspired mechanisms and so these
are some of my past Works where I was
working on basically endoscopic robotic
add-ons so robots that you could put
around the tip of an endoscope and they
would lie flat as you are navigating
your way for example in the anatomy and
so not hamper navigation of colonoscopes
for example but then when you reach the
surgical Target area they would unfold
pop up and help perform
some some level of surgical task and so
for example in this case expanding and
anchoring the colonoscope tip to enable
better Force application better Force
output during procedures and all sorts
of other things and so this is what is
interesting about this is that as you
probably know soft materials and rigid
materials don't interface really well
and so if you want to build a robot out
of this you need to be very cognizant
about
the how you're going to be bonding these
materials together how are they not
going to delaminate
and so we basically developed
Manufacturing Technologies based on soft
lithography laser Precision micro
Machining and chemical surface
modification borrowed from again soft
lithography realm to create
mechanisms that were that are super
tight these are my fingers over here and
by using microfluidics we are able to
have these soft radio ductuators move
around
they can do pretty large range of motion
and also we were able of embedding
sensing so achieving proprioceptive
actuation for example in this case we
have a capacitive sensor and as our soft
micro actuator is expanding we're
capable of tracking the motion of this
robotic actuator but you could
potentially also think about
for sensing and other types of sensing
again
so one of the things that we did with
this technology was developing like I
mentioned robotic add-ons so for example
multi-degrees of Freedom robotic arms
that could be placed at the tip of a
colonoscope to perform tissue
manipulation and especially one thing
that is called
tissue retraction so in this case over
here you can see that we have a vacuum
gripper as the end effector of the robot
and the the arm is basically helping
lifting this tissue up so that we can
perform
tissue biopsy and so on
so that was part of my previous work as
a postdoc at Harvard and I was
approached by a neurosurgeon when I
moved to BU who was very excited about
this technology and told me oh can we do
something for you know
narrow surgical procedures on a daily
basis I am trying to access tumors
located in a very deep position within
the brain and like I mentioned they can
reach that tumor then postoperatively
they have complications for the patient
right and the reason why they have these
complications is that basically they're
using
stainless steel spatulas that are pretty
rigid and they have no sensing of course
embedded onto them and so really the
procedure looks brutal these instruments
are medieval if you will right so the
surgeon doesn't really have much
information about how much force they
are applying onto the tissue why is
there not a robotic technology that can
make these procedure you know more safer
I would say so we have developed this
soft origami inspired robotic retractor
that can basically squeeze into a really
tiny configuration and be inserted
inside the brain by passing through your
nostrils or maybe a bird hole in the
skull and then create a working channel
for the surgeons to operate where they
can insert instruments and they can see
the tumor that is located inside
um so of course we were able to
characterize the system but what's most
important is that we validated it in an
in vitro simulation
procedure where we were able to see that
of course the robot because it's soft
and it has multiple
um like a like a larger surface it can
interact with brain tissue in a safer
way and exert
forces at a level that is more
controlled than traditional rigid
instrumentation and so that was
something that we were really excited
about and hopefully we're moving forward
and right now actually oops and right
now actually we are looking at
integrating sensors on this structure
too to not only measure the forces uh um
in a continuous way throughout the
procedure but also what we want to look
at is integrating sensors that can track
for example brain activity during the
procedure this is really exciting
because you can have really robot
you can really have a robot that is
interacting with the human and the the
tissue and return information about for
example physiological
entities physiological information to
the surgeon as they are doing the
procedure and hopefully be even more
safe when it comes to performing
Neurosurgery
um and last but not least I just want to
mention quickly
um recent work that we currently are
doing on soft rigid robotic systems and
this is worked by my PhD student Brian
who has developed a
um really interesting manufacturing
technology again based on laser
Precision micro Machining and chemical
surface modification of soft materials
to make sure that he's able of
integrating these soft origami inspired
actuators inside origami rigid
structures
and the way he's doing that is by having
everything so there is no manual
assembly of these uh soft actuators
everything is really sort of like
already thought about as a batch
manufacturing procedure so you can scale
these down as much as you like you can
easily assemble them pretty quickly
without error without human error and
the cool thing about that is that you
can integrate again sensing in this case
we're looking at ionic resistive sensing
and we're using the fluid that we are
using for actuation also as a sensing
medium and so again combining all the
pieces of a puzzle when it comes to
robotic actuation sensing and controls
and Brian was able to develop different
types of joints and and degrees of
freedom so over here we have linear
rotation rotation versus translational
combined and this is the response of the
sensor and because these are again again
hybrid robots we can use the benefits of
Both Worlds and so
this goes back into basically having
rigid robots and we all know how to
predict the motion of rigid robots and
model them right and so when we are able
of doing that we can track predict their
position we have sensors embedded that
return us every type of information we
need to know about where the robot is in
space how it is
um moving and so on over here we're
tracking with an em tracker with an
electromagnetic tracker the position of
the robot but really the response that
you're seeing here is the response of
the ionic sensors that we have in our
robot in our integrated in our robots
unfortunately one of the problems here
is as you can see there is wiring
problems that we still have to figure
out many wires are coming off of our
robot but one challenge that we were
able to solve with this manufacturing
technique hopefully you'll hear more
about this because this paper is in
preparation is the integration of
fluidic lines and so you don't see any
fluidic lines over here because they are
all integrated within the robot
yeah so I just I think I'm on time I
just want to conclude by uh thanking uh
well of course big shout out to my lab
my students uh over here I think I
mostly talked about the work that Max uh
who is my most senior graduate student
has been doing and he will be graduating
over the summer Daniel rukaya Viola and
a bunch of others Franco Brian and Aaron
and then a bunch of other Masters
students and undergraduate students in
the lab so big thanks to them really
lucky to be working with them and of
course I want to thank my sponsors and
collaborators and thank you for your
attention and I really appreciated you
coming to the seminar thank you so much
for having me
[Applause]
great thanks I'm not actually can I kick
it off
um I was curious in these medical
applications about fluidic or Airlines
going into the body are there concerns
about bursting like you know the actual
Drive mechanisms for the robot compared
to things that you actually want to
deliver and what kind of challenges are
there for safety
[Music]
are relatively low pressures but because
you know these actuators if they were to
pop yes you would have
um like fluids squirting out of the the
actuator I guess so one of the reason
why we're looking at specific
applications like for example
colonoscopy where we are using saline
solution to actuate our robots is that
it would be safe if you had a leak
um you know within the colon basically
uh in Interventional colonoscopy
surgeons are already using those type of
pressurized fluidic lines with saline
solution so it's something that has
already been used in this field which we
consider you know being safe
for
um Interventional bronchoscopy
applications we are using air you don't
want to have like fluids within the
lungs for sure so using air again
gives you that level of safety
in terms of pressures again and forces
that you would be expecting if one
actuator were to fail
these are
if you're looking at forces that are
applied typically to the lung tissue
during rigid bronchoscopy they are
in a very high range so we're talking
tens of Newtons and so that gives us
enough room to think that these
actuators would be safe to use in this
scenario but then again definitely there
is more work to do and we're hoping to
be validating these systems in Vivo like
I mentioned really soon on live animal
models to evaluate safety concerns and
so that's one thing on the other hand
because one thing that I probably
haven't stressed enough is that these
robots that I talked about today are all
conceived with having in in our in our
mind the idea of using them as
disposable so no need to you know
sterilize them and have them undergo
many procedures and that gives us a
little bit more room for safety because
they will not be used for many many many
many cycles and so hopefully the risk of
an actuator failing is lowered by that
great thank you
other questions I'll go here and then
here
foreign
thank you for the talk it was very
interesting I was curious for your
bronchoski applications
I think a lot of the actuators have one
degree of freedom in general for
broncospi is one degree of Freedom
enough or is there any benefit if you
um additional yeah so currently in
bronchoscopy
um
so a system like for example this one
that I'm showing over here a traditional
bronchoscope has one degree of freedom
for
for traditional endoscopes in general
you typically have one degree of Freedom
unless we're talking about colonoscopes
that are slightly larger where you can
get to degrees of freedom Peach and yaw
typically you only have one degree of
Freedom with traditional instruments and
so what you end up doing is the
clinician rotates from the outside to
achieve a full range of motion
with our robot we obviously want to do
better we want to do more and so what we
are looking at is potentially using
um let's see if I have it here yeah so
the we have multiple working channels
that we can integrate into the section
of our robot for this first prototype
that we developed we had a working
channel for the camera two working
channels for instruments and one working
Channel over here which is actually
closed up at the end of the robot and it
works as a Pneumatic chamber that helps
us steer the robot around but there is
no reason why you couldn't have an
additional working Channel somewhere
else to have two degrees of freedom so
definitely yes we would love to have
that and at this time is more of a I
guess compromise because you're looking
at miniaturizing these as much as
possible to get to remote locations
within the lungs
and so it's a compromise of how much
complexity you want to have on board of
the robot but hopefully yeah that would
be possible
thank you yeah
um I I work at intuitive but not
specifically on our ion products so I
don't know that much about the lung
geometry I was wondering if you could
elaborate I saw your sort of
necked down actuator and you're talking
about how most cancer nodules are sort
of deep deep into the lung
how does how does the geometry on this
actuator that you've created
um
I guess compared to those very very
small
orifices at the edge of the lung
um sort of I guess how deep does it does
it penetrate oh yeah
sit on
basically if you're looking at a
traditional bronchoscope they typically
range in diameter about six millimeters
or so there are some smaller ones sort
of like pediatric bronchoscopes however
they don't really have so the smaller
you go
and you know you don't really have
working channels and so they're
traditionally just for Diagnostic
procedures but not really like
Interventional tasks you don't have any
instrumentation passing through so as
you're scaling down with these
instruments you're losing some level of
capability
and so with traditional bronchoscopes
you know you can reach these are cold
Generations so every time you have a
bifurcation you call it generation and
so you would be able to probably reach
two or three generations and then you
have to basically deploy tools uh
without
um Vision Direct Vision guidance from
the camera but under
um x-ray screening and navigation and so
if you were to push further
sometimes you can but it has been proven
that the stress that you're applying on
to the tissue is way too high and so
past procedure patients typically have a
supportive complications and tissue
trauma and bleeding and scarring and
again it's not ideal when you have a
person that already has lung cancer
right you don't want to go that way so
with our system the diameter is less
than a half almost and so that is a good
um
thing because we hope that we are going
to be able to proceed further than the
third generation on a live animal model
without causing that much tissue trauma
because the the tissue the sorry the
robot is soft and hopefully because it's
a automated sorry because it's um
has robotic technology that allow you to
steer the robot and Propel it forward
and see what's going on inside you
should be able to see less tissue trauma
as well we're hoping to basically assess
these capabilities X Vivo first before
we're moving to live animal models and
so look at scratches on the explanted
tissue whether or not there has been
trauma before you know we move forward
we have time for one more question
so great talk I I'm very interested in
to your soft gripper work that that you
showed and I wonder what would it take
to integrate it maybe somehow with
existing commercial rigid surgical Robo
systems such as a da Vinci soft gripper
so yeah so you're talking about the ones
that can detect contacts and that you
was used to you know deliver haptic
feedback to the surgeon
so yeah
yep let me
is it this one
no actually it's a gripper the one that
was used for bacon place
oh
okay
hold on is it over here this one or
maybe you're referring to okay gotcha
yes great
um so the question is how easy would it
be to connect this to like a da Vinci on
the wrist yes yeah so over here
um
as you can see I'm hoping that you can
see something over here there's a little
bit of light going through the wave
guide right
um here and here there are Optical
sensors in there you go over here so
these Optical sensors the good thing
about them is that you can manufacture
them for example with soft lithography
and microfree micro fabrication
techniques and so you can scale these
down so for a system like this one I
believe the diameter of our sensor was
about 100 or 200 microns but you can go
even lower than that and we have also
been able to prove that this technology
we can use with
um
um micro
tubings such as these ones over here
we're still able to guide the light
through these tubings are quite large
but we've been recently able to
demonstrate that you know with really
tiny tubings like 100 or 200 microns
medical tubing you can still achieve
these uh capabilities soft Optical
sensors so I think one thing that you
need to consider when you're talking
about an instrument like The DaVinci is
definitely you want to scale the sensor
down as much as possible to make sure
that it's going to be able to integrate
on the gripper of the system and it's
definitely possible because you don't
have you know this is an optical sensor
so there's only light passing through
the sensor no
current no voltage no temperature and so
on and so yes it would be definitely
interesting to look at that and and and
it could be definitely possible yes
okay with that I think we're at time so
thank you all very much for your
questions and thank you Sheila for the
great talk thank you so much for having
me